what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so Donnie Cates is writing dr.
strange right now and in it's a maitla
it's absolutely amazing the arts okay
the arts the art could definitely be a
little better but do the store do the
store is amazeballs okay so this is this
is nuts
dr. strange becomes God and then fights
the god of death that's basically what
this is ah and it's and you guys what
you guys are gonna be amazed to find out
who it is okay so initially this whole
thing picks up with the character of
someone meeting with an old man now
those of you guys who have not been
keeping up with Doctor Strange zelma was
a chick who was introduced when Jason
Aaron was writing dr. strange during
all-new all-different marvel and Zillah
was just a chick who kind of wandered
into the home of dr. strange requesting
help for the fact that she was basically
infested by demons and that led into the
empirical storyline and the empirical
storyline was really like Jason Aaron's
way of kind of bringing in the the 1990s
Doctor Strange stories and what I mean
by that is back in the 19th well really
yeah the 1960s 1970s there were no rules
when it came to magic so Doctor Strange
could literally do anything he wanted to
like if writers wanted him to do
something they would just invent his
spell it would be like well Doctor
Strange has a spell that allows him to
do virtually anything he wants to ah the
problem with this was that it made it
virtually impossible to tell compelling
stories
it's like compelling stories of Silver
Age Superman how do you tell a good
story about a character who can
literally do anything and so because of
that in 1982 and Doctor Strange sorcerer
supreme issues 48 through 49 I'm pretty
sure there was a story called demons
death and what this basically did is it
brought forth this idea that the Vashon
T where Doctor Strange gets a large
brunt of his power had called on him for
a favor to basically help them fight a
war and Doctor Strange said no and the
result was that they stripped him of a
huge amount of his power and he was
replaced with brother voodoo I think it
was eventually Doctor Strange came back
but he came back with his power reduced
it was a way for for Marvel to kind of
nerf his abilities and so he went
forward as a master of the mystic arts
kind of and so from that point you know
up but really up until the modern day
he's never been as powerful as he was
back in the 1960s that's why we refer to
the original Doctor Strange back in the
60s and 70s as quote-unquote classic
Doctor Strange and then you have modern
Doctor Strange they're basically the
same character with two extremely
different levels of power but Jason
Aaron had used the empirical storyline
to basically have this race of
individuals who went through the entire
like you know all these different
dimensions and the main Marvel Universe
and we're killing off magical
artifacts and by extension quote unquote
killing magic itself and so what this
did is it reduce the amount of magic
that was in the Marvel Universe by a
pretty huge margin now since the defeat
of the empirical Doctor Strange has been
kind of working his way back up but it
was kind of a restart more or less it
was a reboot for the Doctor Strange
mythos more or less where he was
starting with smaller spells and then
working his way up to higher levels of
power and so ever since then
zelda has basically been an apprentice
of sorts and her ability to use magic
has actually grown by a pretty huge
margin but this blind man kind of walks
in there and I guess really this old man
kind of walks in there with her and it's
like hey look like what in the world's
you know where's the sorcerer supreme
and the response is Elma iswell Doctor
Strange is gone I don't really know
where he is and in the end the the the
old man follows up with a second
question no where's the real sorcerer of
supreme Loki and so basically this
immediately picks up with the idea that
Loki has replaced Doctor Strange and so
following this it really kind of shifts
over to the bar with no doors of course
the bar with no doors is basically
invented by Jason Haran and it's a place
where like all these different magical
wielders in the Marvel Universe
congregate the difference here is that
Jason Aaron II kind of established this
somewhat ambiguous rule that there is a
price to be paid for magic what that
price is was never really solidified
never really set in stone it was just if
you use too much magic then there you're
gonna have to pay some kind of a price
somewhere online it's kind of weird but
it was a way to sort of curb the power
of Doctor Strange it's like this is why
he didn't like routinely fix everything
all the time is because there were
limits there were rules that if he used
too much magic a price would have to be
paid now the response at low key here is
that that rule is stupid like it's it's
a nonsensical rule and it actually kind
of works here and the reason why is
because in Marvel Comics most magic
wielders are mortals if Scarlet Witch is
walking down the road and black widows
pissed off because Scarlet Witch got
with Hawkeye and black widows angry
because she really wanted Hawkeye shoots
Scarlet Witch with a sniper rifle she's
dead there's that's the end of Scarlet
Witch but someone like Loki he's a god
like he's a god to his base that
basically is in possession of the powers
of Doctor Strange how we got dr.
Strange's powers we don't know yet but
because of the fact that he's a god he
kind of comes along and says look okay
sure maybe there's a price to be paid
for wielding magic but that price
applies to you guys it doesn't apply to
me because your physical mortal forms
can only tolerate so much pain suffering
in the dimensional death whereas I as a
god and basically immortal so long as I
eat the apples that I do and so you know
that's that's that's it for Loki and so
from there he's just kind of like what
I'm
looking for is something called the
Exile of sing soon and it's kind of
interesting because this is somewhere
we've never really heard of before and
the response of everybody is just kind
of laughing at him and saying this spell
does like this this spell you'll never
find it like no one knows where this
spell is but Logie really responds by
one just kind of you know losing it and
to actually like teleporting everybody
out of the barks now the other half of
this which is actually kind of
interesting is low-key as texting Zoma
you say hey I kind of screwed up no
one's gonna help me out and I'm gonna be
late because now Thor is here I mean
this is kind of a funny situation but
Jane Foster being here is just kind of
like you know okay you know Loki you
gotta stop your schemes whatever you
know and it's kind of interesting
because Loki's actually trying to be a
good guy here and the way he shows that
is he says there's actually frost giants
who were invading Earth who were working
to invade Earth right now I stopped them
but the reason why you didn't know is
because they have a spell that hides
them from the eyes of Heimdall otherwise
he would have told you something but
Heimdall couldn't see him he didn't know
they were there and they're basically
using dark magic in order to pull it off
and so it's Loki being a good guy so of
course this sends Jane Foster on her way
and from there we end up finding out the
Doctor Strange is taking up residence as
a well basically as like as a better
veterinarian with a dog named bats that
talks but what is it going on is there
is a door inside the sanctum sanctorum
of Doctor Strange that is always kept
locked and there's no spell that Loki or
zelma know and can find that will open
the door meaning Doctor Strange is the
only one that knows how to open it and
so they're completely unable to access
you know what's on the other side of
this wall it's an interesting situation
because Doctor Strange is kind of
meandering around town of course talking
to bats and then you know Loki starts
making the moves on zelma now this
immediately sends Doctor Strange into a
panic and the reason why is because
zelma is currently holding back a bit of
the knowledge she knows when it comes to
magic but if she divulges everything she
knows then that means that Loki will be
previewed information that dr. strange
didn't give him when he relinquished the
real ingresses position to Loki himself
and Loki will basically and be in
possession of like the full totality of
dr. Strange's powers and so what you end
up having is Stephen strange who shows
up on the doorstep and says look you
know we got to get out of here Zellman
freaks out because she's like hey look
like what in the world it's kind of
funny because Loki you know doctor
strain is like hey man you stole my girl
and Loki is like no you lost your girl
like this definitely seems like
something out of Jerry Springer but the
fact remains here
the doctor strange gets rucked pretty
readily and because of the fact that
he's really not a match for a Loki
because Loki's in the totality of all
these powers and Doctor Strange has a
full you know a few spells left to
himself what is up happening is he's
basically kind of forced to go about his
way but not before bats dies and the
reason why is because bats has a weak
heart and of course Loki basically
creates a spell that keeps bats encased
and bats heart fails and bats dies and
it's like the saddest thing ever you
know he's like don't let don't let
anyone hurt your friends you know it's
like no bats like we didn't get to see
him very long we didn't get to spend a
whole lot of time with bats but we had
some great moments I liked him I enjoyed
that but this really kind of sends dr.
strange off on like this grander plan
right and that's one of the things that
really came out of Jason Aaron's run
with the empirical did you basically had
this idea that Stephen strange had to
come to the realization that with there
being so little magic out there in the
world he had to kind of get back to his
roots right because ever since he
trained with the ancient one and ever
since he became the new sorcerer supreme
after the ancient one died it's always
been magic solves everything you know
but once once magic was kind of reduced
he really had to just kind of rely on
his own personal resolve and that's
what's going on here
what he ends up doing is he ends up
traveling out to a house in the middle
of nowhere and seeks the help of a guy
and this guy says I'm not helping you
like I don't want to have anything to do
with this and of course the the response
to Stephen strange is well I mean look
you got to help us anyway
and this guy's response is but you know
what happens when I try to do good
things what I try to do good things bad
things happen to everyone and Stephen
strange responses yeah but we fixed that
and so ultimately what is I'm happening
is this guy says okay fine I'll work
with you and Stephen says but yeah but I
don't need you Robert what I need is the
century so this is Robert Reynolds the
century has returned like I'm so excited
about this man oh man I love the century
and so because of this what we end up
finding out here is there was this great
big huge tournament that was held
basically that was held by the vishanti
and the vishanti it essentially kind of
imposed this on dr. strange and now the
result of this was that dr. strange had
kind of you know won the tournament but
the the vishanti basically stripped him
of his various spells at his disposal
and said we've selected a new sorcerer
supreme this new sorcerer supreme is
loki and so because of this like
basically loki became the new sorcerer
supreme because the vishanti chose him
to be to be the new sorcerer supreme
however if that seems kind of silly and
nonsensical to you ah it does because
you're not getting the full story so
pick up with what's
right now you basically have this kind
of being explained to Robert Reynolds by
by dr. strange and it's kind of
interesting because brother Reynolds you
know the century of course he really has
those three personalities right you know
the century the void and then Robert
Reynolds himself but the centuries just
kind of like look I told you I would
help let's go ahead and help nobody end
up finding out is that Doctor Strange is
actually leading century to the house of
long and it's kind of funny here this is
funny encounter right he's like hey Wong
you know you gotta help and Wong is
basically answering the questions of dr.
strange before Doctor Strange really
finishes asking the questions and and
it's funny because centuries response is
wow man you guys have a real rapport
like it must be because you guys fought
together for so long and because you
guys are you know you guys have this
magical bond and you know as in strange
like actually I texted him and was like
yeah any emailed and he called and he
would not leave me alone but ultimately
Wong basically says to Stephen strange
look I understand what you want to do
here but what you're looking to do is
not something that you can just walk in
and achieve because you're talking about
an extreme level of power now I remember
Wong is very very experienced he's seen
everything Doctor Strange has done he
was a tutor for a bit for Doctor Strange
in his early days but like Wong is
wildly experienced here he's just not
the sorcerer supreme at the moment and
so Wong has a lot of pearls of wisdom to
offer and he's very familiar with these
various dimensions that are out there
and so what we end up finding out is
that the plan of Doctor Strange is to
travel to Asgard and this is actually
something that we've never seen before
not so much strange travelling to Asgard
but what he does while he's here of
course what he's looking to do is to
basically find Odin right like basically
speak directly with Odin and to you know
essentially ask a particular request the
problem with this is that remember the
war of realms in the Thor god of thunder
storyline is going on which means that
at this moment the time the story's
being written Freya is honored as you
know seems to be on her deathbed and
Odin is tending to her side and the
result is that Odin's brother Cole is
basically steward of Asgard he's the one
that's ruling in the stead of Odin
himself and of course Cole is very very
hardcore right he's just like you know
no Outsiders allowed now of course dr.
strange got here by hiding himself you
know from from Heimdall but if act
remains here that where Cole and
everyone is just kind of like look we're
not gonna let you do this this is when
the century is invoked and it's kind of
interesting because this is not the
first time we've seen this right like if
you're not really familiar with Marvel
Comics on the surface you would be like
okay no way this century will be able to
hold his own against as guardians
actually he would we saw that in siege
on Asgard right like in the events of
siege on a scar
Norman Osborn was director of shield he
grabbed his century Robert Reynolds
basically swindled him to his side and
then Robert Reynolds destroyed the
entirety of Asgard and Broxton Oklahoma
and so because of this like Robert
Reynolds is an exceedingly powerful
character that was powers wax and wane
based on the story that a writers
telling any one point in time so while
you see him facing off against as
Guardians and holding them off with the
greatest of ease you may see him
struggle against as Guardians by a
different writer because that's what the
story calls for so again it really kind
of bounces around but the idea of dr.
strange is actually to travel to the
world tree of a Drasil and to basically
gain all of its power now again this is
not something that we see very often in
fact we've never really seen this we've
never seen anyone ever harness the power
of a drusilla the closest we got was
when Thor you know when when Thor
Odinson gained the powers I guess really
you know gained access to that to the
runes and by doing so became rune King
Thor and was basically God mode but
aside from that like that's about the
extent of it but ultimately like Doctor
Strange makes it essentially sacrifices
the body of bats to Idris so and then
like intersil itself stashes up dr.
strange and imbues him with 100% of its
power and so Doctor Strange in turn like
travels back to earth and faces off
against Loki now this is kind of cool
because this is when Doctor Strange
becomes insanely powerful right like you
know the way this stories written by
Donnie Cates Doctor Strange the same
things like I've never had this level of
power before I'm way beyond anything
I've ever been before ie he's way beyond
classic Doctor Strange I would say this
is probably Doctor Strange his most
powerful form and so from there what he
ends up doing he's travelling directly
and facing off against Loki to basically
bring down his existence as sorcerer
supreme and reclaim the mantle for
himself now of course this is a
requirement right I mean when someone
becomes a new sorcerer supreme like what
if Doctor Strange relinquishes that role
if he says I hereby retire and I grant
you the mantle of sorcerer supreme
abroad of all those all that magic goes
with it Doctor Strange can still access
a few things but he's nowhere near on
the same level as Loki who's already
adept in magic and then has all the
sorcerer supreme artifacts and power at
his disposal but with Doctor Strange
here using the power of Idris silk and
amplifying all of his magical energy and
knowledge he is well beyond Loki and is
actually pretty cool because these two
fighting actually starts transversing
these different dimensions it's almost
like a throwback to secret Wars - when
when molecule man and Beyond are fought
each other and he was just sending
shockwaves throughout the multiverse
because the battle was so extreme and so
intense but the
the craziest display of power here and
this is something that that no magic
wielder that I'm aware of has ever done
when Doctor Strange and Loki are
teleported to you what's essentially a
hell dimension because there's a lot of
dimensions that are basically like hell
and Marvel Comics Doctor Strange using
the power of Idris L like re
materializes the entire dimension like
he literally transforms the whole thing
and it's Ennis edits nuts like he turns
of demons into like little furry bunnies
which are adorable like like all these
all these insane things and so again
it's a wild level of power but the
response of Loki is you have a mortal
form you will die one day of old age
like what you're doing here is going to
require an insane price and this is when
we find out Robert Reynolds is the one
paying the price for this because he's
so powerful because he really is on the
level of a god he's just you know more
or less taking in the price quote
unquote that has to be paid for all the
powers that dr. strange is using and so
in the midst of all this because you
have Stephen strange and you have Loki
who were facing off against each other
the zelma actually just kind of happens
to be wandering by because you know
coming back from the store I guess
anyway she shows up basically casts a
spell to nullify his powers for three
minutes and so this essentially leads
into her kind of saying hey look you
guys need to talk it out and of course
Loki's still having the power of a god
kind of gets the upper hand now this is
when things get awesome because the
response of Stephen strange you know
when when Loki says open the door like I
want I want this spell
open the door strange says okay look
like I'll open it man just be aware that
like whatever happens next is on you and
the reason why is because as soon as the
as soon as the door is open by dr.
strange a kind of darkness begins to use
out and this is when we find out that
it's actually the void and it's the
craziest thing because Loki's scared out
of his wits right like oh my god and
this is crazy
because he gets free gets knocked out of
the building right she's like Brandi
goes flying elma comes over we have to
run we to get out of this place and the
reason why is because the void is here
and it's kind of crazy because remember
the void killed Loki like that's what
happened during see John Aysgarth Robert
Reynolds destroyed a scart lost control
the void emerged and killed Loki on the
spot I mean it was just like BAM like a
deer was it was it was Kurt whose drapes
curtains it was it was Loki the god of
mischief and dying at the hands of the
void like it was it was pretty beast now
of course at this point like what you
end up having is the void who's kind of
like pushed out of Stephen strange his
body right like using the various magics
available to zelma and Loki
strange is essentially freed but he
really doesn't like have any of that
power left right like all that power is
basically gone and this is when we find
out the the spell of the Exile of seen
soon is a spell that will actually
revitalize magic more or less the LEAs
that seems to be the case and that's
what this was kind of crazy is because
magic you know seems to have been dead
but like this spell basically brings it
all back now in truth this is Donnie
Cates way of setting things back to
rights rightly yeah like Jason Aaron's
run magic was dead Donnie Cates brings
it back let's go forward with Doctor
Strange that's really how this whole
thing works and so everybody who was
ever you know who lost their magical
abilities they're amplified back to
where they were before so this is kind
of a way to fix everything that was
going on with like Illyana Rasputin and
with Scarlet Witch now whether other
writers follow suit we don't really know
because in Marvel Comics the left hand
doesn't really know what the right hands
doing but still like like with regards
to these guys facing off against against
against the boy remember you're talking
about an insane level of power the void
is extreme in its abilities and so when
it comes to like Loki and and you know
Doctor Strange even with all their
powers it's still one hell of a fight
and it takes all three of them plus
Robert Reynolds to push the void back
into this you know giant vault more or
less and for the door to be sealed the
fight doesn't last that long but it does
serve his purpose the void is
essentially exiled again it's locked
back up and then Robert Reynolds freaks
and the reason why is because this is
what was done that when you had Robert
Reynolds as the void Doctor Strange had
split the two but the responsive
Reynolds is you let the void out like I
understand why you let the void out the
void will destroy everything which it
will it would annihilate everything like
we saw that in siege on Asgard the the
what-if story it's an extreme level of
power but what you ended up having here
is Reynolds you kind of says look do not
talk to me again now of course this will
probably segue into Jeff Lemire century
solo series so kind of have your eye out
for that it comes out of the end of June
on the 27th so this probably segues
directly into that either showing us
what was going on before this story
picked up with Reynolds or what's gonna
happen after all this but then what we
also end up finding out here you know
zelma kind of tells Loki look tell the
truth like if you don't tell the truth
then I'll tell Stephen strange and so we
end up finding out here that Loki had
cast the entire tournament as an
illusion right like there was no
tournament like using his magic he
tricked dr. strange into believing the
vishanti had created the tournament and
said the winner of this tournament will
become the new sorcerer supreme Stephen
strange had kind of won but then was
stripped of his power release was told
by the vishanti a new sorcerer supreme
will be chosen
and the result was that dr. strange
under false pretenses relinquished all
of his power to Loki now on the surface
the idea seems to be that Loki's doing
is for the sake of just being a bad guy
rhinos egg wolves what Loki does you
know he tricks sorcerer Supremes into
giving him his power and then kind of
runs amuck and screws things up a little
bit you know it's kind of how it goes
but what Loki actually does is he makes
a really compelling case here he
essentially says to dr. strange a race
of people showed up on earth healed
magic and there was nothing you could do
to stop him there was nothing you could
do to defeat these guys now they were
just regular beings like I could have
destroyed them because you're a good guy
and because you want to do the right
thing and so on and so forth that's your
weakness
Loki's whole whole idea here is there is
evil out there there are events out
there that you are woefully unaware and
there are things that are coming to
earth that are going to turn everything
you know and love upside down the war of
realms the whole like damnation of Earth
the gathering of the Infinity stones and
of course the final host of the
Celestials woe betide Doctor Strange
when that happens because it's like
you're not ready I mean you're talking
about cosmic God Celestials coming back
for a final host you couldn't defeat a
race of beings who wanted to do it or at
least you couldn't immediately stop a
race of beings from destroying magic how
in the heck are you gonna stand any
chance against cosmic beings with the
power with with powers well beyond your
ability to comprehend and so ultimately
you know it's like I did this in order
to teach you how much you don't know in
order to teach you how I know where to
show you that without magic
you are painfully incapable like you are
completely inept if you do not have
magic at your disposal if you're going
to win these conflicts you have to be
more than just a guy who uses magic so
it's actually a pretty important lesson
that Loki's teaching here he kind of
offers a few explanations here and there
whatever and then ultimately dr. strain
says fine get in my cloak and get out of
here soon as Loki - a hell dimension
following this zelma quits and again
this is Donnie Cates kind of setting
everything back to just standard dr.
strange stories worse just Stephen
strange by himself but again kind of a
reshuffling a reworking of things this
will go forward into Marvel's fresh
start or wherever in the heck you'll
call on it and it'll just be there the
you know it'll just be dr. Stephen
strange by himself but still it's a
pretty solid story it's a pretty cool
way to kind of set things back to rights
and sort of Eliminator I just really
remove a lot of the things that Jason
Aaron did that I guess Marvel didn't
really like that much I have no idea but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here - comments explained it makes
you guys at the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]